tu sais quoi en quelques heures j'ai eu
un million de vues de gens qui venaient
à mon secours
donc j'ai envie de dire merci
jean-marc pastorino qui est l'organe de
la barre dont le patron de l'armateur il
m'a châtié et je pense que c'est pas
possible d'abord pour les varoises et
les varois qui m'adorent j'allais faire
rire pendant 59 date c'était cool le mec
me vire avec un seul et unique argument
qui est à mon avis doit pouvoir passer
sous le coup de la loi
c'est de dire on peut pas prendre un mec
qui a raconté la blague de la déchirure
à la télé qui est ce mec qui peut dire
tout d'un coup j'annule ce qui n'a pas
reçu des pressions jean-marie peut-être
c'est peut-être eux